[Música]
convidá-los reflexões para nós
começarmos a nossa palestra
quantos de vocês é seu propósito de vida
quanto vocês vivem do seu propósito de
vida de uma maneira sustentável rentável
agora na vida de vocês
o futuro é múltiplo versa abundante
brilhante potente porque ainda estamos
gertran tanta escassez hoje em dia pra
todo mundo tem que competir farinha
pouca meu pirão primeiro
quem comprar em comprar isso compra
aquilo acumular como la como esse
acúmulo todo só afasta e exclui as
pessoas
estamos aprisionados pelo medo batendo
cara está pagando o boleto batendo
crachá diminuindo não ousem se diminuir
em viver a vida a quem do seu estaleiro
com o freio de mão puxado olhando o
professor para o retrovisor é loucura e
por isso temos uma sociedade tão doente
e fora
o mundo é feito de infinitas
possibilidades e você você você
são seres únicos
vocês vieram ocupar um espaço que nesse
mundo e esse espaço vai ficar vazio até
que vocês conheçam o seu propósito de
vida e descubram porquê de estarmos aqui
hoje
meu propósito de vida é ajudar as
pessoas a conhecerem o seu propósito de
vida e para manterem manifestarem ele de
uma forma sustentável e rentável
eu vivo há dez anos
assim de uma maneira leve de uma maneira
sustentável com alta responsabilidade
o projeto dólares é verdade ele já teve
vários nomes mas sempre foi a
manifestação do meu propósito de vida no
mundo
passamos por 15 estados diagnosticamos
aproximadamente duas mil empresas de
todos os tamanhos e mentor amos 30
processos de startup mentor amas 25 mil
entre fizemos 25 mentores individuais e
de aula pra 60 adolescentes
essa galera toda já está vivendo
experimentando o paradigma da abundância
e deixando a escassez para trás
vou contar pra vocês uma história de
duas pessoas muito queridas larissa
mentor e ela por aproximadamente 18
meses
no começo o diagnostiquei que larissa
precisava ampliar seu conhecimento
técnico e também melhorar a gestão do
tempo dela durante o processo
nós criamos ferramentas metodologias
para apoiar o desenvolvimento do
trabalho dela e os resultados aparecerão
rapidinho ela ganhou três prêmios e até
uma viagem pelo trabalho
o thiago é um querido
ele chegou com muitas idéias muita
energia mas também com muitas crenças
limitantes e ele não conseguia fazer
a idéia dele decolar que o que aconteceu
durante a jornada que nós tivemos
nós começamos a desenvolver estratégias
e eu comecei a perceber que as crenças
limitantes dele também era um
e foi um processo de descoberta
meu ele para criarmos uma nova realidade
hoje o thiago depois de uma longa viagem
em porto de galinhas está empreendendo
aqui no rio e eu estou dando palestra no
hotel sem sapatos
uma mulher abriu as portas desse evento
dora diz construiu uma tecnologia
colaborativa experimental integrativa o
perfil comportamental de cada um dos
clientes
nosso propósito é ampliar os horizontes
para que vocês vejam além das lentes da
escassez e recalcular a rota e o rumo
das vidas de vocês nosso nome começou
com o mágico de oz e é usando a fábula
que eu convido vocês a pensarem numa
trajetória para criarmos uma nova
realidade
a estrada dos tijolos amarelas começa
quando cada um decide sair do papel de
acomodado o acomodado ele é passivo
todos estão contra ele
o mundo é contra ele
então quando você se auto responsabiliza
pela sua vida pelos seus atos e consegue
tomar o papel de protagonista da sua
vida você sai do olho do furacão que a
vida parece te quando nós terceirizamos
o nosso poder pessoal
logo depois a gente encontra o coração e
faz um mergulho profundo em olhar sua
sombra
suas luzes seu potencial e integrar isso
tudo de uma forma que você se olha de
frente e transforme crenças limitantes
em crianças em poderá dores mas vocês
concordam que não só de coração se vive
nessa vida não é o cérebro precisa ser
alimentar e no tributo por muito
conhecimento de qualidade livros cursos
workshops artigos tudo inclusive a tal
palestra sobre propósito de vida do tex
isso produto pep para que a transpiração
gerar inspirações e agora é a hora do
leão rugir com vontade com coragem e
colocar tudo isso que foi o tufão foi
feito durante as outras etapas numa
forma integral numa solução para as
necessidades do mundo
e aí pessoal a história começa de
verdade a brincadeira
agora é colocar o seu propósito de vida
numa ideia sustentável e rentável no
mundo e bater os seus sapatinhos e co
criar a realidade que vocês quiserem que
eu queria convidá los para fazermos uma
visualização fechem os olhos por favor
eu gostaria que vocês pensassem agora no
maior sonho da vida de vocês
aquele sonho que faz o coração de vocês
baterem forte sinto um cheiro
pegue olsson sons dêem o máximo de
realidade possível esse sonho ao ponto
de quase tocá lo mas nesse momento vai
descer uma parede de vidro na frente de
vocês e vai separar vocês e os seus
sonhos
abram os olhos
vamos agora a partir de agora destruir e
10 criar todos os obstáculos todas as
barreiras que nos impedem de colocar na
vida no hoje o nosso só os nossos sonhos
e propósitos de vida sim ou não
o mundo vai ser um lugar incrível quando
cada um de nós estiver ocupando seu
lugar
executando e criando soluções com seu
propósito de vida pra vocês
o que eu desejo caminhos abertos fluxo e
sonhos realizados sobre
[Aplausos]